what's going on guys
Suicide Squad biggest August box office
opening ever but the critics were so
down on it that the fans wanted to shut
down Rotten Tomatoes what do we make of
all this and what effect do we think it
will have on the DCU going forward we're
gonna talk about that very thing today
and we have our own little Suicide Squad
to talk about it with hey guys first
it's his first time on the show he's one
of the co-hosts of the et Cie show and
he's a voice in the new Transformers
combiner wars welcome Ricky Hebert hey
thank you so much for having me I'm very
excited I can't believe it's her first
time on the show she's one of the
co-hosts of Summer Movie report and from
FX movie download welcome Sasha Pearl
raver thank you that's very sweet of you
call me one of the co-hosts cuz it's
actually summer movie report with Dan
Morell so I'm just proud to be in the
same set a correspondent yes indeed and
this handsome young fellow is one of the
writers of honest trailers and an
all-around swell guy welcome back
Joestar thank you how so Suicide Squad
it was a huge opening critics were
divided you guys all saw it first
you know let's what are your thoughts I
don't think the critics were divided as
much as they were all just like
completely bashing the movie and I think
it was justified I mean the first time I
watched it I was really excited I was so
pumped I was sitting there like a little
boy on his birthday and then it happened
and I was like this isn't what I wanted
at all by but I saw it again
I saw it a second time I did see it a
second time I was like there has to be
some redeeming factors here and you know
what I liked it a lot more the second
time again note having the lowest
expectation knowing what happens I was
able to find things that I liked and
find things about characters that I
originally liked in the first screening
that I liked what you had to mine for it
a little bit Sasha where did you stand
right out this is insane I'm still so
shocked that people have been so
dismissive of this film I enjoyed the
hell out of this movie yes the villain
sucks yes there are third act problems
but here's the concessions if you walk
out of a film and the overarching thing
is how did it make me feel how it made
me feel was I want another one
Joestar I'd love to hear from you what
are your thoughts on Suicide Squad this
movie was awful it was poorly paced it
was a
million different cooks in the kitchen
trying to go in different directions it
had some great performances that quite
frankly it did not deserve to have
weirdly this was my favorite Will Smith
role cuz me he was good he was great it
was this great combination of welcome to
Earth Will Smith and serious business
actor Will Smith that I loved and this
movie did not deserve it I think we have
a pretty good mix here we have someone
who was on the fence about the movie and
found stuff to like about it someone who
really liked the movie and someone who
was not pleased right that's a good mix
let's talk a little bit I want to talk
about where DC and Warner goes from here
do they listen to the critics do they
hear their clarion call and like oh we
got to change the way we make these
movies or is the box office the final
arbiter of this and they're like oh yeah
the movies making money well the movies
not making as much money as they hoped I
mean I think everybody hoped that it
would open about 140 so it was about 5
million below that still I think that
they're already making so many
adjustments like we've seen the Wonder
Woman trailer that looks rad we've seen
the Justice League trailer that looks
rad I know I think I think Wonder Woman
looks great I think Justice League I
don't have the faith that I would have
had a year ago in it I actually like the
Justice League trailer I was surprised
but I like funny Bruce Wayne he reminds
me of Michael Keaton's Bruce Wayne you
know right immigrant you know that that
Bruce Wayne was super fun to me as far
as the future of the DC Universe I think
they've already been listening to
critics and they're making these
decisions they've put Jeff Jones in
charge Suicide Squad was mostly done by
the time they really started doing the
shuffle so maybe it's me just being way
too hopeful but now my line of thinking
is when how the Jeff Jones DC movies
start and things will start to clean up
a little bit how much do we think the
world of Suicide Squad is going to
factor into Justice League I think that
if the Suicide Squad comes back it's
definitely going to be more about Harley
Quinn I think we're going to have more
of the Joker I don't think that the
Jared Leto stuff was all that we're
going to see I wonder though with Will
Smith I think you have to go with the
lesser characters I'm glad that Jai
Courtney showed up and made me fall in
love with him in a way that he never has
before cuz I've never understood how
people felt like they could rest a
franchise on his show likes his
performance I didn't feel like Captain
Boomerang factored in a lot but that's
why I think he's the kind of you can't
get Will Smith to come in
Justice League and B seventh fiddle or
eighth fiddle to those other characters
you catch high court need to do that and
I think that that makes more sense
I think the Suicide Squad moving forward
though you've got these really strong
characters that were strong I think more
cuz of performance than anything else
and you know you take Harley Quinn you
take Deadshot you can move them into
these other franchises you can move them
into their own movies I'd watch six Will
Smith's Deadshot movies today
I love Terry - your thoughts how do you
think Suicide Squad is going to proceed
going forward are they going to be
divided and peppered into the DCU
overall or do you think we'll see that
Suicide Squad pop up in other movies a
Suicide Squad - maybe even a Justice
League versus side squad mmm I think
they learn their lesson about verse
movies I don't think anybody learn the
lesson about V movie you're absolutely a
completely different is Sony PSPs I
really hope it's not because I think
that they will succeed the most when it
is sort of a unified front and they're
going against hopefully a stronger
villain I will admit that the villains
in general have not been great but I
think that they'll pepper in the smaller
characters in different ways sort of
like how we have the flash showing up
for like one quick little second because
you know he's available it's harder to
get Jason Momoa Jai Simha more cost more
money to go against the fact that they
would face each other I think they did
way too much work in Suicide Squad to
make them relatable and and to make them
feel more human and for you to enjoy
them as characters to just put them
against if that would be a really bad
move if they if they had them fight I
think but I think peppering them in like
even if Will Smith doesn't show up but
it's Deadshot with the mask on and he
shows up in Justice League and like
takes out a high-value target or
something like that that they need help
with sure that could work
sure okay and taking a look from Warner
Brothers you now have three films that
have underperformed critically and I've
done decent maybe a little less than
they would have hoped at the box office
do you just keep going saying hey these
critics they don't get us man they don't
get me I'm just gonna live in my mom's
basement and play my guitar man and
smoke we know the critic there that are
they going to just say the critics don't
get us or are they going to try to
adjust and be like yeah let's bring more
people into the fold let's try to get
some
critical good grace in regards to our
future films I think they already are I
think that with especially Wonder Woman
we're really seeing that shift toward we
want to make prestige films we want to
stand toe-to-toe with Marvel and we want
to do better things but I think the
thing that has really raised the bar
more than anything yeah was Deadpool
I think Deadpool shifted the playing
field in a way that now we're going to
start seeing a much bigger and more
resonant way they want to do good movies
I just don't think that they found their
footing this time around and I don't
think that they're going to give up I
think they're going to see it through
but then I don't think they're really
gonna have another like Christopher
Nolan style DC movie in this universe
that they're building right now I've
been so excited about this movie I want
all of these movies to do well when
those first Joker promo images came out
and everyone wants this I was like shut
up guys it's gonna be rad we're all fans
and if Warner Brothers were to cling to
this idea that like because they're
doing it in talking points well we made
this for the fans
well those fans aren't going to make you
the money that you want to be making
they're not going to keep these films
successful in theater as long as you
want them there you know they wanted
Batman vs Superman to be running forever
oh yeah yeah you know and so they need
to do some quality control and really
kind of get everybody back on board
because you have extreme fans that are
going to love DC movies no matter what
that are gonna love Marvel movies no
matter what we're always going to turn a
profit yeah they're always going to turn
a profit but they're not always going to
do what the studio needs them to do yeah
they want to destroy worldwide
box-office yeah yeah I think one of the
one of the things that they don't get
for some reason is that it's 2016 and a
lot of these critics are huge DC fanboys
and they want these movies to be good
and when they aren't as good as they
should be that's what makes people upset
well but then you have to think about
one thing which is my biggest concern
which is trying to please everyone the
thing is is when you see a Marvel movie
you know what you're getting when you
see an Adam Sandler movies you'll know
what you're getting so there just has to
be a clear vision because when Nolan was
making his Dark Knight trilogy he wasn't
thinking I have to please everyone
same with Zack Snyder the problem is is
no one stepped in to say okay you
have to please everyone but you have to
please more than just yourself final
question Jeff John's calls you
personally and says I want one piece of
advice going forward about what we
should do with the DCU
what do you say let's go right down the
line Rick God make Zack Snyder director
of photography and give the directing
duties to some great up-and-coming
people like the way that Star Wars and
Marvel is doing nice
uh yeah hire Lord Miller and trust your
franchises to them for at least two
movies ooh
yeah give me a sword & Sworcery medieval
demon Knights movie hmm Wow a road less
traveled where do you want to see the DC
you go how did you feel about Suicide
Squad critics verse box office let us
know in the comments section below we
want to know I got to thank this awesome
panel Ricky thank you for coming by Oh
Sasha what a pleasure
Joe yeah I love you buddy thank you for
watching I'm how run to kick me up on
Twitter by bike in a world where every
network spends millions to get the
attention of Emmy voters the only way we
knew how to build high for our own Emmy
nomination was to make fun of the TV
shows the voters work off wait wait wait
go back we got nominated for an Emmy
like an Emmy Emmy that's awesome
but wait then why are we making fun of
all their shows this is a terrible idea
you guys